niger's military leaders have informed
the French government that diplomatic
immunity has been removed from French
Ambassador Tunisia Sylvan ittay and
they've instructed authorities to
proceed with eviction France has said
they don't have the authority the
military leaders Who removed niger's
president from power on July the 26th
told the French Ambassador last week
that he had 48 hours to leave after he
refused to meet with the Junta appointed
foreign minister let's go straight now
to our correspondent in Paris Natasha
Butler and Natasha are in quite
extraordinary news perhaps not
unexpected given the recent events but
have we heard anything from France
yes the French Foreign Ministry have
reacted they have told us that they have
seen this requester from niger's
military leaders they acknowledge it but
they say that those military leaders
have no legitimacy no right to make such
a request because Paris does not
recognize them as legitimate rulers in
Niger now ever since July France has
repeatedly condemned uh the coup d'etat
in Niger it has repeatedly asked the
military leaders to reinstate president
uh Mohammed uh bazoom there is no doubt
though that this latest escalation this
latest event this request from the
military leaders is going to be an
additional cause of concern uh for
France for Paris for the French
government who have said over the last
few days that their Ambassador Silva ite
will stay will remain in Niger it is
going to be a worry for them and the
French Foreign Ministry have told us
that they are looking again and
reviewing their security operations and
the situation around the embassy in
Niger
okay Natasha Butler thanks very much for
bringing us the view there from Paris
let's talk now to our correspondent
Ahmed Idris he joins us on the phone
from Naomi in the capital of Niger I
know you are actually at the French
Embassy at the moment you were
struggling to actually connect to a live
with us because there's quite a lot of
police there at the moment tell us what
the situation is
about a dozen military and police
vehicles are now in front of the French
Embassy and we see constantly Security
Forces most especially soldiers are
crawling the streets around the embassy
and the residents of the uh Ambassador
the French Ambassador here so it's still
a tense situation I spoke to one
military personnel and I asked him what
the situation is like he said they're
just waiting for orders to execute they
know
um the plan probably could be to cut off
any Communications on any link with the
emcee or the residents so they're just
waiting for orders so right now that
shows that nothing has been decided yet
as to the eviction of the French
ambassador from the residence and the
embassy but right now what we see is a
tense situation uh when we passed here a
day or two back the presence of security
forces wasn't as much as it is today so
probably we may see someone action very
soon okay just remind us why the
Ambassador Ambassador ite had fallen
foul of the military rulers
well to start with it's a long process
to start with uh I think the final straw
was when the ministry for foreign
to a meeting and he he failed to turn up
and uh simply because France doesn't
recognize the authority of the military
Junta here so he didn't go and the
military here feel insulted and they
want him to leave now remember when at
the start of the coup when the coup was
announced the French rejected the coup
they condemned the coup and they
insisted that uh the post president
Muhammad bazo must be returned to office
immediately and that they are in support
of whatever I've seen the economic
community of West Africa States want to
take including of course the use of
force so basically uh that sort of made
things worse for the Ambassador since
then he's been holed up in his uh
residence and the embassy here in near
me and he was not allowed access outside
the embassy and that situation continues
you're just going to eat after the
exploration of the deadline given to him
by the Niger military authorities to
leave the country now probably we'll see
more of these uh height intentions on
Saturday when another deadline will pass
when the French military coups here in
Niger are asked to leave the country
following the exploration of one of the
defense agreements between France and
Nigeria indeed okay very interesting
indeed um Ahmed thanks very much for
bringing us the scene there from outside
the French Embassy in Naomi well David
Shin is the former U.S ambassador to
Burkina Faso and Ethiopia and joins us
now live via Skype from Washington DC
Ambassador great to have you with us it
sounds like Niger is gearing up to
remove ambassadorite from the country do
you think that will happen
well certainly the authorities in dma
the Nigerian authorities are in a
stronger position than is the French
Embassy they have the security Personnel
on the ground and if they really want to
push this issue they can the question
remains do they want to have that much
of a crisis in their relationship with
France and they may decide that it's not
worth that but it does look like that is
where this is headed I mean all
indications are that they do think that
it's worth it so far they're certainly
pushing and pushing what will be the
implications if it's hair is forced to
leave
I think in the final analysis the French
government will be in no position except
to allow the departure of the French
Ambassador uh that will be uh
unfortunate from the standpoint of
France but their their position is just
not that strong on the ground at the
embassy that's the problem that that
France faces at the moment and also I
mean you've been an ambassador yourself
to Burkina Faso and to Ethiopia if you
can't do your job or you won't do your
job which is to meet the people in power
then is there any reason for you to stay
well one could argue that it really
serves little purpose of course the big
difference is is that France does not
recognize the military government as
legitimate government so it has no
particular interest in interacting with
it anyway uh it considers a former
president bazoom to be the legitimate
leader of Niger and would be perfectly
willing to interact with him but not
with a military regime so you have a
very unusual situation here probably not
unique but it uh I'm not aware of
anything quite like it in my experience
I was going to ask you if there's
anything
to protect Sylvan it in this situation
or our ambassadors diplomatic immunities
subject to the whim of whomever's in
charge
uh according to the Vienna convention
which covers uh diplomatic immunity and
diplomatic relationships the recipient
government in this case Niger has very
widespread authority to ask for the
removal of any foreign Diplomat in other
words to declare them persona non grata
and that is effectively what happened
here the problem is that France does not
accept the edicts of this military
regime because of the way in which it
took power so you have some very
interesting legal issues that the
international lawyers may have to sort
out at some point in the future but in
the meantime there's this very practical
problem on the ground
and one wonders whether France perhaps
overestimated its influence in Indonesia
because it hasn't been able to show any
leverage over the Junta and its demands
to for it to reinstate Muhammad bazum
I think France probably fully
understands uh what it can and cannot do
in the country uh it was probably hoping
that Cena heads would Prevail and and
the new government and allow this to
play out in a manner that both sides
could say a face that doesn't seem to be
what's happening however
okay Ambassador Shin thank you very much
for taking the time to join us there
from Washington DC
thank you